And now zooming
to the meat of the program,
let's play tonight's
#HashtagWars.
(cheering)
Tonight it's very cool
to have Jeff here.
Wilco's a fantastic band.
You should see them live
if you get the chance.
So, comedians,
not every song can be a hit,
which is why tonight's hashtag
is #OneWordOffSongs.
Examples might be:
♪ Get out of my car ♪
♪ Get into my car. ♪
Uh, I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock, and begin.
Jen Kirkman.
Um, "I Am Trying
to Break Your Fart." Come on.
Hey! Perfect!
Points.
That's a Wilco song.
-Look it up. -It's a working...
working title.
-Dave Koechner. -This one's
semi-autobiographical.
Uh, "Started As a Bottom.”
-All right, points!
-(laughter)
Jeff Tweedy.
"Ob-La-Di-Al-Qaeda.”
-Yeah, points.
-(laughter)
Points. Koechner.
-"(bleep) on Eileen."
-Yes, points.
(laughter, shouts)
-Yeah, just changing the tense
really does... -Yeah.
-Yeah, Jen.
-"Nothing Compares 2 Jews."
-All right, points.
-(laughter)
Dave Koechner.
"Hey. Hit My Baby
One More Time."
-All right, points.
-(laughter)
Jeff Tweedy.
-"Sweet Home Williamsburg."
-Yes, points.
-(laughter)
-Jeff.
-"Devil Went Down to Hooters."
-Yes, points!
Points. Also looking
for a soul to steal.
-Jen.
-Uh, "Smells Like Teen Scrotum."
(laughter, shouts, cheering)
Thank you.
(applause, whooping)
Jeff Tweedy.
-"Dude Looks Like a Dude."
-All right, points! Perfect!